the jurogan experience it's a perfect
time to have you on
i mean this is uh i mean when we're
talking about free speech in the time
when the president of the united states
has been banned off of twitter and
facebook and it's
right it's a wild time what do you make
of that
well you know facebook and twitter
are private publishers right i mean
whatever
we don't exactly know what they are
they're not exactly like the times
or like uh nbc or abc
um but they're close they're they're
certainly in the private sector
and and the private sector has always
had
has always had the discretion it's their
first amendment right to decide
who to publish and who not to publish um
you know it's different with facebook
and twitter because they
claim to be uh platforms
like the telephone company that you know
anybody can use to have
conversations but they're
they're not quite that they they really
are a lot like a publisher
and you know the times decided to fire
one of its columnists
uh because it didn't like what he wrote
they have a first amendment right to do
so and they're not the government
so you know and that to that extent
um what facebook and twitter did
is perfectly legal and
and not really different than what a
publisher or a broadcasting company
would do
if it decided to uh to change
or or fire one of its one of its
anchors or one of its columnists
on the other hand they are sort of like
a platform uh like an electronic soapbox
that they've erected
in a in a park and invited everybody
and anybody to come and when they start
picking and choosing
uh no you're not good you're not good
you're okay
you know they when they stop being a
gatekeeper uh
you run the risk of them closing people
out
of of uh a national dialogue
and depriving people of an audience
basically
and that that's a problem and it's a
problem we haven't figured out
how to work out yet uh because this
medium
is in its infancy you know it's people
forget that
that the printing press started in the
15th century in 1400 and something
and it took hundreds of years before
uh freedom of the press
and uh worked itself out in ways that
we're familiar with now
and we're you know we're right at the
beginning of this
internet speech uh medium
and uh it's hard it's hard it's hard to
say
uh i i think facebook and twitter
had the right to do what they did in
banning trump
um but the question is if they start
banning anything that they don't like
then they're really closing off the
public conversation
to people and what what's the criteria
how do you do that
yeah it's also it seems to me that we're
using these outdated
things to compare like uh comparing it
to the printing press or comparing
facebook or twitter to publishers
or even comparing them to something like
a utility
like the the power there's something new
there's something completely different
and
we i mean i hope it's not going to take
hundreds of years to have some sort of a
freedom of expression
online in these things but they're
monopolies it's not like anybody could
have bought or made a printing press
and printed their own books or printed
their own newspapers not everyone can
make their own twitter
you know it's too it's so complex and
there's so many users on it
it it yeah there's very few places where
you can like legitimately
get your word out in a way that you can
with twitter or
express yourself but you know and it's
true that these
this medium is analogous to utilities in
some ways
analogous uh to publishers in some ways
but they are new yeah and they're
different that's that's right
but but consider this when i was growing
up
uh i was a teenager in the 50s um
a big problem with free speech and
the democratization of free speech was
that nobody
had access to anything i mean you had
the times you had the washington post
you had the hearst newspapers you had
nbc and abc and cbs
and that's where most speech occurred
and nobody had access to that
um so even with even with the
monopolistic
bans twitter and facebook
are doing these days or can do have the
power to do
the fact is is that
many many millions more of people
ordinary people
have access to huge audiences uh
than did uh 50 years ago um
uh you know if you couldn't get into the
times and you couldn't get into the
washington post and if you couldn't get
onto television
you could speak you were free to speak
but nobody heard you
yeah and so you know it's a lot better
now
even even with
questions about abusing the power of of
being a gatekeeper that twitter and
facebook have
yeah it's uh it's just such a strange
time for this
because it's uh in the middle of the
like we're at the end of the president's
run he's still in office but yet
he's you know everybody wants him out as
quickly as possible
because you're wondering what he's gonna
do and he can't really express himself
uh publicly anymore it's it's just so
strange
yeah well of course you know he's still
the president
if he held the press conference uh
everybody would cover it
um and he you know if if uh
i used to say uh back in the day that uh
you know
my father was a construction worker with
a fifth grade education
and uh if he had something to say he
could say it to me
he could say it to our family at
thanksgiving but
uh he didn't have access to an audience
of the kind that roosevelt had when he
went on the radio
and he couldn't get into the times as
easily as as the governor of new york if
the governor of new york held the press
conference
so you know it isn't it isn't different
than that
in that respect i'm not too worried
about a president
not having access uh to a public
audience
a president has tremendous power uh
to attract attention and and that that
was true a hundred years ago
um what i'm worried about are ordinary
people
what i'm worried about are are
are people like you um uh people
you know who have something to say um
but
their freedom is that they get to say it
in the closet you know where nobody
hears them
uh you know there's an interesting story
uh a real case that happened in the 60s
when james meredith who was the first
black person to
enter the university of mississippi uh
was shot when on his first day there
and it was it was a real outrage it was
in the early 60s
and a a man named sydney street
uh a black guy living up in harlem in
new york
uh was so angered that
you know he he he wanted to say american
ideals
uh american principles of liberty and
equal rights
have just gone up and smoked today and
if he had stood on a street corner at
145th street in harlem
and stood up on a soapbox and said that
the only people who would have hurt him
were a few dozen people who passed him
on that street corner
so what he did is he got out in the
street corner and he burned
an american flag it was his flag he
owned it
so he wasn't destroying anybody else's
property he burned the american flag
and by burning the american flag he
attracted television cameras
which his words by themselves would not
have attracted
so the television cameras came and he
got to say i'm burning this flag
to symbolize the fact that if a guy like
james meredith can get shot
just for going to school uh america's
ideals have gone up in smoke
and he got onto the six o'clock news and
and millions of people heard it heard
his words
and he was prosecuted for burning the
flag
which was a crime at the time and his
case eventually went up to the supreme
court the supreme court
overruled it and said it was symbolic
speech uh
but but the reason that i'm telling that
story
is that is that it it demonstrates how
before there was an internet people had
to figure out
dramatic things to do uh to get their
message
uh to more than a handful of people and
that's why
you know benjamin spock burned draft
cards that's
that's that's why sydney street burned
the flag
uh that's why there were demonstrations
uh
instead of just instead of just words
and
and uh you know it worked all right uh
for some people
but for the most part uh most people
could not get their messages out
to large audiences until the internet
came
and so even with twitter
and facebook acting as gatekeepers in
ways that
trouble us uh because we don't know what
the limits are
we don't know what the standards are and
we don't know why we should be
having these private people decide who
gets to hear what
but even with that this
the ability of ordinary people today
to reach huge audiences with whatever it
is they want to say
is much much larger i mean by by orders
of magnitude
larger than it was 30 or 40 or 50 years
ago
unquestionably um but it just concerns
me
when a corporation has the ability to
dictate
even if it's a problem president even if
it's someone is
as crazy as trump just when a
corporation gets together and they side
decide
that this guy can't use their platform
anymore a platform that hundreds of
millions of people use it's just
it just seems very strange well it is it
is
it is a problem because there are no
standards right and
that's what that's what i mean when i
say we're just the beginning of thinking
about
how how to how to do that i mean here's
here's what
what i see as the issue
if you allow facebook and twitter
to make these decisions in the same way
that you allow
the times and the washington post and
and and television networks
uh to decide what what they publish
um then you run the risk of
of arbitrary exclusions
from from people's speech
reaching large audiences not just the
president
who has alternative alternative means
but ordinary people the only way to
remedy that
is by law the only way to remedy that is
to give the government the power
to regulate what these corporations can
do
and all of our history shows that if you
give the government the power
to regulate speech you're going to be in
a lot worse shape
than if you allow the private sector to
do it
because who in the government are you
going to give that power to
um you're going to give it to trump
you're going to give it to giuliani
you're going to give it to joe mccarthy
um
you're going to give it you know to to
roosevelt during the war
who might have barred japanese americans
from speaking to large audiences
i mean who are you going to give that
power to and
our entire history shows that the only
way to regulate
private power is through government
power and if you
regulate speech through government power
and you give the government the power to
decide who gets to speak and who doesn't
get to speak
we will be in far worse shape uh than we
are
in in having the private sector do that
catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience